다 장사하시는 분들 보면은 장사 너무
잘하시고 다 하는데 이제 부동산
투자나 이런 거에 관심 없으셔 가지고
그 갑자기 쫓겨나고 예 그 뭐 다
아파트 산다 그러고 차 산다 그러는데
아니 그 장사하는 사람은 그게
중요한게
[음악]
아니잖아요네 안녕하세요 사람입니다 어
제가 오늘 인터뷰하신 분은 장사하고
있는 건물을 매입하실 주변 쿠바
사장님을 또 모셨습니다 또 이번에 저
한테 설계도 좀 맡기게 돼서 저
bsn 그 김준석 소장님도 같이 좀
모셔서 이야기를 좀 나눠보도록
하겠습니다 리모델링을 계획하게 된
혹시 계기가 있으실까요네 우선은
리모델링은 제가 가게가 오래됐어요
여기서 벌써 이제 8년 차에
들어갔는데 8년 되셨어요네 이제
가게도 낡아가고 있는 상황이고 그
많이 감사하게도 많이 찾아 주셔서
가게가 잘 되고 있거든요 그렇다
보니까 뭐지네 공간도 저희가 더
효율적으로 써야겠고 나중에 사업적으로
2 3층도 연계해서 쓰고 싶다 보니
전체적으로 이걸 손을 봐야겠다는
생각을 했습니다 아네 아무래도이
건물이 용적률이 꽉차 있잖아요 그죠네
그래서 시기는 너무
아까운서 제가 봐도 딱 리모델링한게
딱 되게 좋은 건물이었는데 김주석
소장님이 좀 이렇게 리모델링할 때
전체적인 뭐 스케줄 이라든지 설계
과정이 어떻게 되는지 좀 설명해주시면
좋을 것 같습니다 표 처럼 우리
건물이 지금 용적률이 초과돼 있는
상황이에요 그렇기 때문에 신축하면 그
면적을 다 잃어버리게 되니까 리모델링
하는게 이제 좋은 방향일 거 같고
여기 이종 일반 주어 지역인데 건폐율
아고 용적률은 이미 다 확보가 돼
있는 상황이라서 엘리베이터에 추가를
해서 그렇게 전반적인 대수선을 하는
그런 과정을 거치는게 좋을 것
같습니다 건축주께서 또 직접 사용하실
건물이다 보니까네 사용 용도에 맞게끔
코어 구성이라 라든지 내부 공간에
대한 무성 그리고 동선 같은 것들
이렇게 협의하면서 결정이 필요할 거
같고요 리모델링 하게 되면은 대수선
허가 진행해야 되고 3층 이상
건물이기 때문에 해체 심의를 받아야
돼요 그래서 해체 심의를 받게 되면
해체 허가 해체 착공 그리고 해체
감리자가 상주하게 되는데이 해체
감리자는 허가권자가 지정을 하게 돼요
그래서 직접 건축주께서 선정하실 수가
없고 구청에서 지정을 해 주는 그런
해체 감리자를 지정받게 됩니다
아무래도 해체 관련된 별도의 인어가
들어가다 보니까 리모델링 공사 기간이
조금 더 길어질 수가 있고요 그래서
전체적으로 일정 한 1년 정도 아
1년 정도네 설계 해체 공사 기간
포함해서 그 정도 예상하고 있습니다
확실히 이게 미리미리 계획하고 해야
되겠네요네 그래서 사실 실제 공사
기간은 5 6개월 정도 예상하고
있어요 근데 앞에 시간이 필요한
것들이 설계하고 이제 해체 관련된
것들인데네 딱 공사를 시작할 수
있는이 시점에 맞춰서 앞에 것들을
미리 계획을 해 놓으시고 예 공사를
하셔야 임대에 관련된 부분이라든지
아니면 공간 활용이라는 이런 것들을
이제 로스 나는 걸 최소화 하실 수
있는 거죠음 그래서 이게 진짜
해체심경 가지고 그거 말고 이제 공사
기간만 생각하시는 분들이 되게 많으
어 저도
그랬어요 저한테 제일 많이 하시는
질문이 리모델링 5 6개월이면 되는데
왜 이렇게 오래 걸리냐 그 말씀들을
가장 많이 하시죠 실제로 그 안에서
뚝딱뚝딱 공사하는게 5 6개월인 거고
이걸 미리미리 준비하는 것까지 해서
넉넉하게 1년을 잡아야 되는 거네네
그렇습니다 뭐 혹시 사장님 좀
원하시는 좀 디자인이 있으실까요
외부적인 것부터 먼저 좀 말씀해
드리자면 돌 재질 느낌에 좀화한 밝은
색이었으면 좀 좋겠다는 생각이 들어요
아무리 뭐 각자 취향이 있겠지만
대중적인 취향은 그쪽이 아닐까 왜냐면
이제 디자인이라는게 저만이 건물을
마음에 들어 하는 것보다는음 두루두루
다 좋아하는 디자인이 저는 그게 좀
맞다고 봤거든요 내부적으로는 저희
건물 자체가 이렇게 높이가 높은
건물은 아니라서 걸리는 것들 없게
깔끔하게 잘 정리된 형태의
디자인이었습니다 좋을 거 같아요 작은
건물 일단 밝아야
돼요음 좀 밝아야 이제 건물이 좀 커
보이고음 아 그러네 그렇겠네요 그래
흰색 되게
좋아 주로 다 흰색으로 흰색 좋아해서
그 소장님 보셨을 때는 좀 어떻게
외관 디자인 하면 좋을 거 저도
대표님 때문에 밝은
색상을 좋아하게 된 거 같고요네
건축주께서 말씀하신 것처럼 인적
건물들이 대부분 지금 주택이 많아요
그래서 빨간 벽돌 옛날에 빨간 벽돌
건물들이 많고 그래서 저도 밝은
계열이 조금 더 잘 어울릴 것 같다는
생각은 했고 건물 뒤쪽에 일부분을
빼고서는 사실 되게 노출이 많이 되는
건물이에요 기존의 주택으로 쓰던
건물이었기 때문에 창들이 이제 되게
작게
일 배치가 있 그런 부분에 있어서
부분적으로 창 확장하고 또 이제 감을
좀 부여하면서 그렇게 디자인을 좀
잡아 가면은 지역 내에서는 그래도 좀
눈에 들어올 수 있는 물 외관이 되지
않을까 생각을 좀 해보고요 내부 공간
같은 경우에는 말씀하신 것처럼 최대한
효율적으로 활용하기 위해서는 공간에
대한 배치가 좀 중요할 거 같고 어쩔
수 없이 구조 보강이 필요할 수도
있어요 그럴 경우에는 좀 내부 이제
배관이나 배성 같은 것들 효율적으로
좀 배치를 해서 철골 구조를 일부
타공을 한다든지 보강을 좀 더
하더라도 그렇게 해서 내부 높이나
공간을 좀 최대한 활용할 수 있게
구성을 해 주는게 필요할 것 같습니다
너무 좋습니다 실례되는 질문이긴 한데
예산은 한 어느 정도 생각하시는지 한
5억 정도는 무조건 들어갈 것 같다고
생각은 했었거든요음 엘리베이터도 넣고
싶고 외관만 좀 바꿔서 하는 것보다는
네네 기능는 엘리베이터를는 건물이
없아 그래서 엘리베이터를 넣는 거를
감을 했을 때는 아 5억은 무조건
들어가겠다 일단 저는 그 정도까지만
생각을 했었어요 근데 요즘에 좀
공사비가 좀 오르긴 해서 아마
그거보다 조금 더 추가 추가될 수
있어서 일단은 좀 최대한 그 금액에
맞게 좀 이렇게 준비를 하면 될 거
같고 공사 진행하다 보면 이렇게 좀
절약할 수 있는 방법들 있잖아 공사비
절감이 가장 어려운
부분인데요 는 리모델링 같은 경우에는
철거 범위를 줄이는게 공사비를 절감할
수 있는 방법 중에 하나예요 왜냐면
철거 범위를 줄이면 철거하는 비용도
절감이 되고 철거 후에 새롭게
신설해야 되는 비용도 절감이 되기
때문에 좀 그렇게 두 배의 효과를 볼
수 있는 그런 내용일 거 같고 외관
같은 경우에는 이제 안 보이는
부분들은 저렴하게 예 그대로 기존
마감 위에 거치만 해서 예 그렇게
이제 색 변 만 준다든지 그렇게 좀
활용할 수 있는 방법들이 있고 계단실
같은 것들도 사실 유지하는게 제일
좋죠 그다음에 투자할 때는 투자하고
줄일 때는 줄여서 예 이렇게 좀
효율적으로 한정된 예산 안에서 예
공사를 진행하는게 필요할 것 같습니다
근데 어려워요 그죠네 왜냐면 저희
설계하다 보면 처음에는 그런 예산
때문에 막 줄여서 설계를 해요 하다가
이제 막 스펙 결정하고 하다 보면
욕심 어 자꾸 올라가요 사람 마음이
차살 때랑 똑같네요네 그리고 특히
이제 세보 스펙들 재료나 제품들 정말
하다 못에 이제 화장실에 저희 양변기
세면대 소변기 이런 거 결정할 때
도기가 거 결정할 때도 가급적이면
메이크 제품 쓰고 싶고 예 뭔가 조금
조금씩 올라가다 보면 결국 이런
것들이 또 쌓여서 큰 차이가 되
이거를 다시 줄이는게 너무
힘들어요네 한번 마음을 잘 다잡아
봐야겠다는 생각을 전는 또 아이디어
중에 하나는 저처럼 장사하는 사람은
그 공간을 쓸 거잖아요 인테리어를
어차피 다시 해야 되잖아요 그니까
같이 복합적으로 인테리어 비용을
녹이는 것도 좋은 방법일 거 같아네
맞습니다 그렇게 이중으로 공사하지
않고 한 번에 같이 공사하시는게
효율적이고 비용 절감할 수 있는 방법
중에 하나예요 그렇죠네 아 저는
사실이 인터뷰로 이렇게 하게 된
이유도 장사하시는 분들이 장사만 하는
것보다는 부동산도 같이 염두를
하시면서 또 이런 공부를 왜냐면
장사하는 사람들을 뭐 그나 인테리어도
하게 되고 공간을 계속 몸으로 쓰다
보면 훨씬 더 빨리 배울 수 있다고
저는 느꼈거든요이 부분도 같이
염두해서 계획하시면 그 한 자리에서
장사도 오래할 수 있고 그러 그 동네
상권도 잘 유지가 될 수 있는 거
같아요 그래서 꼭 장사하신 분들 이런
부분 잘 얻어 가셨으면 좋겠어요
실투자금이 생각보다 그렇게 많이
들어가지는 않는 거 같고 대출을 잘
이용하면 이번에 만약에 리모델링 하게
되면 또 이제 시설 자금 대출도 한번
좀 생각해 볼 수 있어서 이번
프로젝트가 좀 이렇게 장사하시는
분들한테 좀 도움이 됐으면 좋겠어
진짜 저도 공감합니다 다 장사하시는
분들 보면은 장사 너무 잘하시고 다
하는데 이제 부동산 투자나 이런 거에
관심 없으셔 가지고 그 갑자기 이제
쫓겨나고 예 그 뭐 다 아파트 산다
그러고 차 산다 그러는데 아니 그
장사는 사람은 그게 중요한게
아니잖아요 그죠 그죠 이번 뭔가
프로젝트를 어찌 됐든 제가 좀 다
담아보려고 해요네 진행하는 것들 그
설계 완성되고 나서 또 이렇게 하고
그 공사하고 있는 과정들 그 공사하고
난 다음에 그런 과정들을 좀 다 담을
예정이니까 장사하시는 분들은 좀 특히
이렇게 좀 지켜봐 주시면 너무 좋을
것 같고요 혹시 마지막으로 해주실 말
있으실까요 뭐 앞으로도 자주
[음악]
뵙겠지요
가는 것도 되게 중요한 능력이라고
생각합니다 그니까 장사를 잘하는 것도
너무너무 중요한 능력인데 영원한게
없잖아요 이런 부동산 적으로도 항상
염두하시고 공부해 보시고 생각해
보시면서 움직이면 두 배 세 배 더
값진 결과가 있을 것 같아서 이런
과정들 같이 공유드리고 좀 뭐
궁금하신 거 있으시면 뭐 댓글 달아
주시면 저도 좀 알려 드릴 수 있는
분만 알려 드리도록 그렇게 하려고
하니까 많이 관심 갖고 봐주셨으면
좋겠어요
네 감사합니다고 소장님도 어 이번
프로젝트 같은 경우에는 어쨌든 저희
건축주께서 직접 사용하실 용도의
건물이다 보니까 그런 부분에 있어서
좀 더 많은 내용들을 협의해야 될 거
같아요 그래서 그런 과정들도 좀 같이
한번 보여 드리면 좋을 거 같고
왜냐면 그동안 임대를 목적으로 했던
건물들 아고는 조금 더 공간에 대한
구성이나 이런 접근 자체가 다를 수
있거든요 그래서 최대한 건축주분께서
좀 이렇게 효율적으로이 공간들을
활용하 실 수 있도록 그렇게 좀 설계
잘 담고네 어쨌든이 지역 내에서는
가장 돋고 있는 건물이 될 수 있도록
너무 좋 너무 좋 열심히 노력해
보겠습니다 아유 감사합니다네 일단은
이번 프로젝트를 영상에 다 담을
예정이고 그리고 혹시 만약에 샤로수길
쪽에
가실거나 하시는 분 계시면 여기 주벤
쿠박 좀 꼭 검색하셔 가지고 저희
이제 프로젝트 하는 거를 좀 진짜
현장 가서 한번 또 보시고 주가 주벤
쿠바 가서 또 식사도 하시고 아 많이
챙겨네 그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지
하고요 다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다